things I wanted to talk about today are
how to get started in homesteading and
self-sufficiency you can't really just
jump in and expect things to work it
just it does not work that way and so I
wanted to do this series kind of like
some tips how I got started not only in
a home setting and self-sufficiency
there's some light but basically how to
become debt-free and about six years
it's taken me you know could take you
longer it could take you shorter but
when I started I had a plan and that
plan is what is crucial and let me kind
of back you up to the beginning and
hopefully that'll help you so I bought
property a house with some land with the
intentions of eventually a home setting
and becoming self-sufficient and also
becoming debt-free and when I bought the
land it was never a homestead before is
actually a vacation home the guy toonder
for 20 years it's on a lake and
basically they come out and spend
weekend or two a year and for the most
time it was not lived in and they mowed
the grass and that's really about all
they really ever did and actually
according to some of the neighbors they
didn't really weather grass that I
wasn't either but doesn't either here
nor there
so things that I think are crucial to
allowing me to get to where I'm at in
such a quick manner or that first when I
bought the house I did not do anything
at all for the first year and that
wasn't intentional because I wanted to
walk the property and keeping a high on
what was in bloom and what I was seeing
for the first year because
it changes as the seasons change you
know everything else changes also and I
was trying to also put together an idea
like where I wanted to have a chicken
coop where I wanted to have goats and
where I was going to put rabbits and
where the garden was going to be at and
you know all these things and my
original plans had to change because
during that first year I found like nut
trees that had I just acted on a whim
and did what I wanted to do from the
start without taking that year break and
paying attention I would have cut down
nut trees that are a natural source of
you know food I would have cut down wild
blueberries and blackberries that are
also a source of food you know I
probably get a gallon or more of
blueberries and blackberries from the
wild plants not counting what I've
planted myself in the nuts and there
were some fruit trees three different
mulberry trees that you know had I had I
done my plan originally without knowing
they were there I probably would have
cut them down because they just look
like trees that weren't on very well and
also I found two plums up close to the
mailbox that really look like they were
dead until till that first spring when
they come to life and I was like oh it's
something growing on there and as time
went on I realized it was a plum natural
wild plum tree and I Mary come pump so
anyways that's what I did I took one
year and I didn't do anything I just
observed observed the property I would
take walks at least once a week
sometimes almost every day I would just
take a walk and I take a piece of paper
and I kind of like sketched out the
property and when I find places I would
mark it on my paper and literally it got
to be so much that I started taking a
GPS and dropping waypoints B just so
that I could find
hey there were nuts on the ground here
where's the nut
yeah you know go back and look go back
and find the nut tree and you know that
kind of helped a lot and I'm glad I did
that because it totally changed my
original layout of the property and it
allowed me to plan where to put the
rabbit hutch without destroying any
natural food or where to put the chicken
coop or where to put the goats or you
know where to put the garden where to
put the orchard all that stuff once I
knew what was here naturally that was
edible then I could plan around that
without destroying it all right so
that's the first tip live on your land
for a year and observe it through all
the seasons that's the first tip the
second tip I want to talk about is have
a game plan and basically what I did was
I kind of knew what I wanted and I'm
just like everybody else I'm kind of
impatient at times and I want everything
yesterday but homesteading is expensive
so you need to have a plan in a budget
for homesteading I'll get it
you know where all this is gonna talk
about that but there's gonna be more
things too so I started with a
spreadsheet and I started with simple
stuff like where am I gonna put the
garden I thought the garden was pretty
important right off the bat that was one
of the first things I did and then right
after that was chickens and really
knowing what I know now I probably would
have went with rabbits next instead of
the chickens but no matter to kind of
touch on why that happened though is
pound for pound when you look at the
cost to raise rabbits and the food they
eat before they're ready to harvest is
much less so than what it is for a
chicken so chickens you got to have like
six months before they even start laying
eggs where rabbits you know you can
harvest them after a few weeks after
they're born they don't really eat a lot
as much or you know not as much as
chickens they're easier to maintain and
pound-for-pound the rabbits beat
chickens every time and I'm still firm
believer and act five or six years now
on the homestead I'm a firm believer
that I probably you know doing it over
again I would have got rabbits but
for I got chickens all right so having a
plan what I did was I created a
spreadsheet and I put down goals for
each year and then I estimated what each
one of those goals would cost me to do
and I'm gonna tell you right now
homesteading is not cheap like unless
you bought an existing home set if
you're starting from like I did a your
home setting from scratch which means
there wasn't a chicken coop on the
property there wasn't goat barns there
wasn't rabbit hutches none that stuff so
you're starting from scratch let me give
you some figures and these aren't
exactly you know if you want the exact
figures I'll tell you these are just
estimates what I know to be true it cost
me about twenty four hundred dollars for
me to build my chicken coop and run by
myself that's what it cost me in
materials and you know time was you know
quite a bit of tongue it was it was
actually spread out over a month because
it rained almost every day that month so
I would get an hour to you know more
work done every day over a month but you
know if if I was going to build it and
have a really good solid weather week
probably would have taken me four or
five maybe six days to build it the
rabbit hutch cost me about three hundred
dollars to build so another reason why I
would have started with rabbits way
cheaper to get started the rabbit hutch
is way cheaper to build than a chicken
coop is and and they produce more faster
so that's another reason why I would I
serve the rabbits the goats the goat is
surprising how much its cost I've got
two of the three sections of the goat
barn done and the goat the fencing the
goat barn that I've got done already the
fencing and the goats have cost me
almost eight thousand dollars now eight
thousand dollars five goats you know so
although that's expensive I think the
rabbits so the rabbit hutch you know 300
dollars and in the rabbits I paid about
a hundred dollars for three rabbits give
or take
so I had $400 in the rabbits and the the
first chickens that I got the chicken
coop and run cost me $2,400
I didn't pay anything for the chickens
so you're looking at $400 vs. $2,400
plus I had to feed them chickens for six
months before I ever got the first egg
where the rabbits only had to feed for
two months and I already had nine
rabbits ready to go in the freezer so
that's kind of how that worked the
garden
I've probably got four or five thousand
dollars in my raised bed garden and you
know materials cost money soil
amendments cost money the fence cost
money to keep out the deer all that
stuff cost money so what I did though
was instead of doing all at once I broke
it down into every year I created a
budget you know what I had income wise
what my bills cost what was left over
how much of that that I was going to put
into the homestead part and then another
section of that I put into paying off
excess debt because I was working on
multiple goals I wanted to homestead
that was one goal I also wanted to be
debt-free within a certain amount of
time that was a second goal and then I
had all these projects to do around the
homestead to get you know all this stuff
done without getting deeper in debt so
that's the other thing you got to do you
got to not get deeper in debt do this
with cash money so you know these people
that I see that are posting all the time
like how much money can we make off our
homestead of this is our first year
should not even be your first work
because you should keep your job as a
way to finance your homestead until you
get an income coming in so that's gonna
be the third tip is you need a source of
income
Wow your homesteading weather you know
if you're married and you're a couple at
least one of you should work maybe both
of you should because that first year
you're not going to be doing anything
you're just going to be observing right
because we are following step one you're
just gonna observe what's on your
property so that you don't go mess
something up another thing was only a
homestead I had a bunch of dandelions
that only grow in one spot of my yard
and that's where I had originally
planned to put the garden had I put the
garden there there would not have been
dandelions for me to make the underlying
jelly with kind of the same way with red
buds now there's a lot of Red Bud trees
on my property but a lot of those trees
would have got cut down because I had
originally planned to put the orchard
somewhere entirely different than where
it was and my original goal was to go in
and cut down all the trees that was
currently there and then build a new
orchard in its place and if I would have
done that I would have cut down several
nut trees several red buds you know
there was just other other reasons why
so that first step is the most important
the second step is figuring out a way to
finance your goals without going into
more debt keeping a job you got to keep
a job the the way that I bought this
property and have done everything that
I've done so I come here I did the
gardens I did the rabbits I did the
chickens I've done the bees I down the
be expansion I've done over 70 fruit
trees I've done hundreds of berries so
many berries I've lost track I don't
even try to count them no more the fruit
trees are simple I can just go one two
three four or five so that you know on
down the line until they're all counted
berries I've got them everywhere I've
planted berries I don't even forgot
about berries but all that stuff takes
time and you might say you know it's
probably gonna take me about two days to
build the chicken coop and it you can
have bad weather and it'll take you a
month and if you are really tight on
your schedule then you're not gonna stay
within your schedule and you're gonna
get aggravated because things are
over-budget and you didn't get
everything you done you wanted to do so
make sure you include some down time
over a lot on the amount of time that
you
it's gonna take I've seriously gotten
any more where if I think something's
gonna take eight hours I just multiply
by ten and that he's surprised how often
had actually works out so you know I
thought it was gonna take eight hours
but it ended up taking Haiti and that's
pretty realistic and that's not a lack
of experience that's just dealing with
things like weather and just stuff that
can go wrong on you know on the
homestead an animal gets sick I've had
to happen numerous time they just
totally mess up my plans for that day or
the next couple of days so that's
another tip what else can we talk about
getting out of debt I did something so
when I started to do this a lot of
people started telling me about Dave
Ramsey and I never followed his I never
followed his like the way he does it but
what I found out was the way that I did
it was pretty close
instead of doing snowball I did
Avalanche and I kind of did it on my own
and I created a spreadsheet to help me
track my expenses and budget and what
I'm spinning out and my goals and all
that stuff so I got some spreadsheets
all linked to in the description if I
don't forget if you hear it in the video
and it's not there remind me I've
actually got blank ones ready to go you
guys have the goats they're like going
crazy because they hear me talking
they're just gonna have to wait that's
kind of like what I wanted to discuss
this is gonna be a multi-part series
because I can already tell I'm at 16
minutes now and I try to keep my videos
you know relatively low so through
editing but there's gonna be a second
part to this video this is only the
first part I have several series planned
I basically just touched on the three
things that I felt is super important
for you to do if you want to get into
home setting and self-sufficiency and do
it without failing because I'm gonna be
honest with you I am now
all my sixth year and if all goes well I
will be 100% debt-free and about between
12 and 17 months kind of hard to tell at
this coronavirus the only thing I want
is my house everything else I pay cash
for or I charge it to a card and I pay
the card off that month so you can do it
you just have to stay focused and you
have to have a plan and you have to know
what you want to do that's for what I
really wanted to say was you have to you
have to know what you want to do you
have to have a plan and you have to have
some money to back it with and as long
as you have those three things home
setting and self-sufficiency lifestyle
is pretty easy to do so stick around for
the next episode of this coming up soon
don't forget to like subscribe share my
videos if you found this useful and if
you have any questions don't hesitate to
ask in the comments